maintenant pour l'avenir c'est de
comprendre ce qu'est vraiment le script
monnaie c'est effectivement pour moi ce
sont des actifs et que l'actif on peut
discuter même du fait que le prêt de les
détenir nous protège de la relation
aujourd'hui et nous protège peut-être de
l'inflation en dollars en euros et
autres il ne protège pas d'autre forme
d'inflation liés au fait qu' énormément
de crypto monnaies secret elles
envahissent en fait le champ
l'univers kipco monnaie est envahie
d'énormément de choix et de variétés
c'est pas toujours dans les mêmes token
il ya énormément de deux jetons
différent et si vous voulez l'univers
lui-même qui a aujourd'hui 2300
milliards de capitalisation il est
surchargé de nouvelles créations de
crypto monnaie donc il faut aussi voir
que ce sont des actifs qui sont reste
moins régulés que les bourses
traditionnelles
je sais que ceux qui défendent les
cryptes monnaie qui travaillent dont
beaucoup défendre la régulation mais ça
aussi on peut en parler ce n'est pas du
tout certain qu'ils aient une forte
régulation là dedans puisque il reste
des cas de blanchiment d'argent des cas
de fraudes et de détournements qui
disent on défie la notion de blocs chine
et la sécurité absolument inviolable
qu'on lui a prêtées au départ même si ce
sont surtout les crypto bourse qui sont
responsables de ces produits
[Musique]